hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Cola this might be
the final chapter this is the last
locale on my map and it has something
like what what what a bunch of baloney
what a bunch of baloney what what about
okay that's one way to start this
episode everyone hi welcome back I died
and went farther back from where you
left off that great cliffhanger ending
we did ha screw that listen I'll be back
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and you're actually back in the same
episode so I didn't need to do an intro
again so welcome back let's just pretend
like I don't even know what happened
which is amazing because I actually
don't know what the hell happened I
didn't see like an inkling that I was
about to die be the way the church is
right there I'm assuming that's a church
anyway I just got to be mindful and not
talk the only problem was the in between
episodes houses standing there like a
doof waiting for people just come up and
say hi to me and poke me in my bum bum
but unfortunately I've smarted up a
little bit in the math math minute back
to paper looking ok I I'm not I haven't
farted that's my that's my confession
I'm actually yeah oh come on what am I
not supposed to go that way huh that's
the first piece of [ __ ] I found in
this game that's [ __ ] [ __ ] ok so
it's my understanding that there's only
a very specific path that I can traverse
this area that needs to be carefully
picked but I don't know how to do that
so ah good perfect exactly what I was
hoping for there's a page right up here
perfect today clearly got worse just as
our moves we're all a little scared of
what happened last night
there were even some suggestions of
going back but that was outvoted we set
off at around 10 a.m. going the same
mansi trail as we did earlier we
encountered a small camp of the local
hunter during our hike we asked if he
had hunted the other night but he said
no he told us a story about a ghost
prowling through the forest in the form
of a bright fog obviously this did not
make us feel better we kept on going
forward
today the hike was slow and difficult
the visibility is close to zero the
temperature dropped to minus 24
centigrade gray around 4:00 p.m. we had
to start looking for a place to set up a
camp we found a good spot on the verge
of the forest covered from the wind as
exhausted as we were we began setting it
up yeah we were too tired to dig up a
hole for the campfire we ate dinner in
our tents we had no strength for any
discussions or thoughts at night I
clearly heard someone walking around the
tent mm-hmm I heard them whispering my
name yeah I do not like to talk about it
with the rest of the group they think
I'm going crazy
you probably are but here's my big
revelation what if that is me like
seriously what if that person that
person's diary that's me and that's why
I'm here because in the intro like at
this game I wandered through an
abandoned village and then I was just in
the camp area here and then I'm just
here you know and also when I'm out of
breath I do sound like I have
a feminine voice and also there was that
moment in the cave where I was on a
whimper movie
so maybe yes baby you know yeah I'm
hoping that this is gonna be correct
because I think last time I tried to go
up on some Hill somewhere I don't know
if it has to do with these rocks
probably maybe I'm gonna die again
so far so good
okay
nothing yet
okay that's bad okay what do I do I
don't worry then we get it where do I go
what do i do where do we get it
Oh in here cool great let me thank you
hi how's it going I'm here now
great cool why did I come in here hello
whoever you are if you were reading
these words yes I beg of you no bus no
we are in the place they call
post-office box five what's I don't know
where this is I don't even know what
year it is they are not allowing anyone
from the outside to have contact with us
they lock us up in cells for in each I
saw dozens of cells like that they
talked about something they called
anomaly seven every day we undergo tests
research tortuous I have seen how they
kill people I have seen terrible things
write about it let the world know they
conduct the worst experiments possible
they have something that we call the
fear chambers where I call my bedroom
there is no way to say what will happen
to the person that ends up there some
come back but are no longer themselves
they are absent others are dragged out
dead only few stay sane I have seen a
bright orange light which spoke to me in
demonic voices and showed me things
worse than any nightmare you can
possibly dream sometimes people come out
of there with broken bones mutilated
crushed irradiated dismembered I can't
take it in anymore take away these
images there is a scientist amongst us
he said that during their sick
experiments they discovered something
out of this world they are trying to
test it the truth is that it is testing
them he told us that there are more
places like this around the world and it
will come a day the gates of Hell will
open you have to stop this destroy it
destroy us kill us all the center is
governed by something that is called the
Soviet research unit for natural
domina I have seen this on an ID card of
the man that was interrogating me he
said we were prisoners convicts
murderers rapists thieves but that is
not true I have done nothing wrong
I hate the war they call us subjects no
names but subjects I am subject 73 I
don't even remember my real name I beg
of you please help us
burn it all to the ground if only this
letter reach beyond the walls of the
center if only the God who promised to
take it has kept her promise you have to
do something I swear by all that one
holds sacred you have to my only
cellmate answer whispers in my ear that
everything's going to be fine
that the orange light is singing in the
voices of hundreds of angel choirs Anton
promised me that if I listened carefully
to the singing he will free me sometimes
however I think that all of this does
not exist there is no prison there are
no bars there are no doctors there is no
Anton there's only this frightening
piercing orange light cool all right
okay that's dough so what do i do what
do I do
what do we do what am I supposed to do
why is there big Bell here all the
orange glow it away doesn't sound good
though what is that well so why was I
killed right outside of here that must
have been like a looks well that sound
is coming from up there and there's a
path that leads meeting me up there so
I'm probably gonna take it great that
sounds good
Oh into a cave the music just hit a sour
note
oh it's campsite hello howdy doody howdy
doody do okay so this here across um
he thinks that means something I should
stand under this precarious throbbing
mountain so what is do that so what is
that how do I get to it
scheme going to tell me and secrets or
not I guess No
oh oh oh oh oh oh I know where I need to
go I know why this here obviously dah
dah dah I need to deport somewhere god
I've never even used this it's a kind of
leveling went the perfect way so whoa
so how does all that do dings it's doing
okay
I'm okay I'm not playing I'm out shovel
wash hell of a dingdong by these words
go the [ __ ] away
excuse me I'm such a silly Billy I three
and so we have reached the end huh we
understood your role in my plan
oh I don't know random victims okay
and nobody is completely innocent don't
know what you're talking about
you may not agree I don't but when the
gates to section 22 open in the world
will see through madness you will
understand that everything I had done
was necessary I don't even understand
what you did what did you did
where the hell am I
what oh my god there's no moon haysoms
seriously what the hell happened here
oh yeah oh yeah I think I'm getting it
this was all just a ruse it was all a
world maddening ruse
okay hello hi and I said nah blah oh man
oh so many questions
oh man I need to make sure I gotta get
out of there just to make sure that
music isn't copier but god damn it boss
ah boy
God is so cool god is so cool I want to
know so much more ah da piss
what was it wasn't aliens was it zombies
wasn't demons I don't know what it was
who was I why was I doing that
oh man alright so thank you everybody so
much for watching this has been a
mind-bending experience there was only a
few bugs in this game which is actually
really cool for it being a new release
like I encountered just few minor little
things there other than that this was
phenomenal oh-hoo so god oh god it was
so good uh I loved it it was so
mysterious it story just like drew me in
the environment was so beautiful the
sound was so amazing the music the enemy
was so mysterious and everywhere and I
mean like there was at one time where it
got me douche alley but every time it
got me it was like I didn't know where
it was coming from it stayed scary
throughout the whole thing because I saw
so little of it and no idea where it was
oh and the environments even though it
was all like in the same snowy every
location that I went to had different
theme to it
like this different mystery to it it was
so good oh it's so good I want to know
more I want to know so much more I want
to know more I got this one of those
games that can't have a sequel though so
this is up to the people who cuz I'm
sure I didn't get every note I'm 100%
positive I missed notes
everywhere so when you guys play this in
the head I recommend you do when you
guys play this let me know or start a
wiki or something about compiling it off
because I got bits to pieces in my mind
little bits of information here and
there but I want it all compiled in like
a story I would love to read a book just
like this narrated by Sean Bean so
either way thank you all so much for
watching thank you all so much for
enjoying this I really hope you did let
me know what you think of this in the
comments below I really want to know
what you guys think of this I'll be
reading them when I post this video but
just thank you all so much for watching
if you have other cool games that you
want me to play let me know in the
comments below thanks again everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye